what behavior do we want right now let's
just say we're the administration you're
the president i'm on your strategist and
we're sitting here strategizing on how
to
fix this economy right now
whose help do we need to know the
president just fell asleep whose help do
we need right now whose help do we need
if you're the president we're the
strategist the economies like this right
now whose help do we need
who's help doing what help do you need
well clearly first and foremost the fed
right you know no no he can't do [ __ ] i
mean he's just gonna interest rate
that's fake right actual economy whose
help do we need to actually improve the
economy uh business owners okay so
hiring okay perfect deployment so right
now business owners are firing
okay that's what they're doing they're
downsizing and it's not just one of them
many of them are right so if you know
that's what they're going through
why do you think business owners are
firing
they're anticipating a recession of some
capacity and they're feeling what's
going on with their businesses right
okay so for example i'm talking to this
guy that's a
a mortgage guy loan officer out of a
hundred loan officers out there okay
when they did loans
did most loan officers what percentage
of the loans they did that they made
money on was a refi what percentage of
the loans that they did the last two
three four five years was a new purchase
for the last two three four years when
the interest rate's going down i'm
guessing 80 percent 75 percent refund
refi
okay so guess what that business is gone
yeah 100 which means you went from
making a hundred grand a month to making
25 grand a month
75 you understand what i just did right
okay sounds good so sure but but let's
go with me here so if you want business
owners if you need business owners
what can you do for the business owners
to not fire these employees what can you
do with them for the next two years
what can you do with the business with
the business owners that are about to
fire right now you're like okay guys
hold off what can you do to get business
owners the next two years to not fire
those people
tax incentives tax incentives for the
next two years
tax incentives for the next two years
remember like
you know the structure is a plus minus
if in the next such and such time frame
you hire five more people we're gonna
give you the five more people you hire
out of 50 of the whatever salary given
we'll give you that as a tax incentive
so if i'm gonna hire five people and
each of them gonna be 50 grand that's
what 250 if you said 50 incentive of
taxes for the next two years 125 now i'm
hiring those five people because we're
sharing that together so the business
owner now sees you as trying to work
with them and a business owner now has
an incentive to not fire those people
but the way you're doing it right now
the business owner is cornered to say
what do you want me to do yeah i have to
make the tough choice so that's well
within the business owner's rates and by
the way of course so who wins there
think about who wins there nobody
in that situation if if we keep those
five people and we don't fire them who
wins
well the employees who else wins
the business hopefully who else wins
the tax pool who else wins everybody the
president wins right the states win
because even you now
don't have the havoc of everyday people
turning on seeing this data
so that kind of a decision-making
process gets people to say
listen we're giving the business owners
more tax incentives do we want to do
that yeah but these guys are keeping
these people as a job that's a good
point and if these people are getting
jobs we don't have crime going up
because if people don't make money they
steal
and they're doing more dumb things of
taking out guns and desperation and
theft
you know what if we do this this could
actually bring crime down and maybe we
see fewer these horror stories we hear
yeah let's kind of work with the small
business owners because because we need
them okay that's how you like when they
did the ppp loan that was just handing
out money i don't agree with the ppp it
was a mess it was a mess no this is
about hey
yeah you're willing to do this i wanted
to give you that when you just said ppp
that's exactly what i was thinking about
what happened over the past few years
where they're just incentivizing people
to keep that state
you have to remember one thing about the
payroll incentives remember the tax
incentives is the federal government say
us us we the people helping the
individual states individual basis you
know why the first dollar welfare is at
the state level the first dollar welfare
your unemployment benefits are usually
at the state level
well that means edd in california that
is where the unemployment benefits in
the state of california are coming from
what's the edd standpoint uh economic
development department okay or whatever
in sacramento edd and so when you have a
business in california you send your
state taxes to edd
so if the federal government says hey
hire those five people and i'm gonna
cover 125 tax incentives the federal
government does that that actually helps
california and it helps individual
states so we the people help the
individual states because the first
dollar welfare is usually at the state
level so that's example of our federal
government helping our state government
and the great handshake as it's called
working so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]